hey everyone it is jesse from the tasty
team and today i'll be testing out four
famous celebrity apple pie recipes see
which one is actually the best on
today's lineup we have recipes from
michelle obama gordon ramsay martha
stewart and michael simon i read all the
recipes measure everything out exactly
as stated make sure it's fair and i got
three my friends place them in a blind
taste so which celebrity is the best
episode recipe let's find out a burst is
the queen of thanksgiving herself martha
stewart she makes a pretty standard
crust in a food processor by combining
flour salt sugar and butter and then she
mixes up eggs and water drizzle that in
and blitzes it a few more times so a
dough forms together
you're going to take that transfer it
onto a work surface and kind of push it
together into a big dough ball cut that
in half wrap each one in plastic wrap
and pop them in the fridge while that's
chilling get a pot over high heat and
melt some butter you're going to want it
to start browning and form these little
speckles on the bottom they'll look
burnt but don't worry it's what we're
going for then you're going to take
granny smooth apples peel them and
you're going to cut them into eighths
they're going to be pretty big chunks
but that's what martha says put some
lemon juice on them toss they don't
brown and get another bowl you're going
to combine some flour sugar brown sugar
salt and vanilla bean mix that up so
it's not really clumpy you're going to
toss that with the cut apples and pour
your brown butter right on top
toss toss toss and you're gonna take one
half of your dough roll it out into a
disc with a bit of flour so it doesn't
stick and you want it about the size of
your pie pan to make things easier you
can roll it right on your rolling pin
then put it right on the disc take those
apples and pour them right in the bottom
and then while that's happening you're
gonna roll out your other dough and put
that right on top as well go around
pinch it so it doesn't come open
and crimp it so it looks nice and fancy
poke some holes in the top let the steam
out
brush the top with a bit of egg to help
the brown
and sprinkle the top with sugar so it
looks nice and glistening pop in the
oven bake until brown and there you have
it martha stewart brown butter apple pie
it's like too much apple it's too much
healthy it's super dry i was kind of
expecting to have cinnamon flavor
there's no slimy at all it's just a
basic apple pie this is as basic as you
can get
up next is my first lady michelle obama
she combines granny smith apples brown
sugar cinnamon nutmeg salt and flour and
pops in their fridge overnight the next
day you're going to butter and flour a
large rectangular baking dish so your
pie doesn't stick and you're going to
grab three rolls of store-bought pie
crust roll those out you want the edges
touching just a little bit and you're
going to cut that in half so you have
one and a half of those
pop that right in the bottom
and poke a few holes in it
and then bring in your apples juice and
all put them right in top it with a few
more pieces of butter take your other
one and a half pieces of pie crust place
that on top and pinch it closed poke a
few holes right on top to let the steam
out and brush it with butter and put it
in a 300 degree oven for three hours yep
there you have it three hour apple pie
this is an apple pie bar this is like a
brownie but apple pie because it's
definitely very flaky but it's
definitely not buttery it's so sad like
this filling is so good
but it tastes like store-bought crust to
be honest
i'm into it
up next is michael simon he starts
fairly standard by combining flour sugar
and salt in a food processor and blitzes
that until combined bring in some cold
butter pretty standard blitz it one more
time but here's the crazy part he brings
in sharp cheddar cheese and blitzes that
right into his dough you're gonna bring
in some cold water pour it on top to
help it come together and if it's still
looking a bit dry you can add a little
bit more just to help it turn into a
dough take this split it in half wrap it
up pop it in the fridge just like the
other ones then meanwhile take some
granny smith apples and toss them with
sugar brown sugar flour cinnamon nutmeg
and salt
toss that together and bring in some
heavy cream and pour it right on top and
toss it one more time
take half your dough that's already
rolled out pour those apples right on
top
dot with a few extra pieces of butter
and bring in your last piece of dough
right on top crimp it closed just like
the other ones poke some holes and brush
this with some egg
and sprinkle it with turbinado sugar to
make it nice and crunchy pop it in the
oven bake until gold and there you have
it a cheesy apple pie
it has a nice iconic
crust sound to it which i love it's kind
of dry
it's like apple pie that's like been
sitting out for like five days this is
as neutral as you get it's not too spicy
it's not too sweet the crust is
wait there's cheese in the crust it's so
weird because there's like this
afternoon of like milkiness and like
mustiness that makes no sense because
usually whenever you add cheese to
literally any food it tastes better but
this is the one case in which it's made
it worse
up next is gordon ramsay he takes a bit
of a different approach with his crust
and combines softened not cold butter
with sugar and adds egg and blitz then
until creamy you're going to add flour
blitz it one more time and if it's
looking dry you can add a few
tablespoons of water with this dough
just like the others you're going to
smush it together divide it in half wrap
it up and stick in the fridge to chill
while that's chilling combine some sugar
cinnamon and nutmeg in a small bowl toss
that together and pour it right on top
of some diced apples not sliced this
time you want to coat them because we're
going to be cooking them melt some
butter and add half of that mixture to
it you want to cook these until they're
really nice and caramelized on the
outside
toss the sauce put those in a bowl and
do the same exact thing with the
remaining apples once those are cooked
you're going to pour them right into a
pie pan with half of your dough
put on the rest of the crust right on
top crimp it close and sprinkle with
sugar bake and there you have it gordon
ramsay's pie
i kind of like it but it doesn't taste
like apple pie the crust tastes like a
shortbread cookie i really like this pie
there's like the right amount of
sweetness the right amount of acidity
this is definitely one of the best
crusts i've ever had that is
crunchy crust that's all i've been
asking for all day
which celebrity has the best apple pie
it's time to find out the second one
actually is my favorite the really thick
one that has like the filling that's
like super brown and caramelly that's my
favorite my favorite apple pie is number
four because it has a really great crust
it's definitely something that i'm
always looking for in the apple after
tasting all of these pies i think i've
come to the conclusion that number four
is my favorite because there was some
dark caramelization going on there so i
was really into that i don't know like
the crust won me over
so there you have it gordon ramsay has
the best apple pie which recipe should
we test next let us know in the comments
[Music]
you